excellencies ladies and gentlemen it's
now my pleasure and honor to welcome the
vice president of the United States
Camilla Harris
[Applause]
We are continuing our tradition that the
US has represented at the Munich
security conference by the Vice
President something that President Biden
started in 2009 and we are very happy
that you continue this we have a
fantastic
transatlantic delegation here the only
difference is that vice president is
when we started 59 years ago there were
only men and now there is a woman vice
president welcome vice president
thank you
[Music]
Krista thank you well it is my honor to
be back at the Munich security
conference
as many of us remember last year on this
stage
I warned of the imminent invasion
of Ukraine by Russia
and let us all recall
many at the time wondered
how we would all respond
many wondered
could Russia be stopped
would NATO come together
would NATO break apart
and would Ukraine be prepared
colleagues
today A year later we know
Kiev is still standing
Russia
[Applause]
Russia is weakened
the transatlantic Alliance is stronger
than ever
[Applause]
and most importantly
the spirit
of the Ukrainian people indoors
and under
Joe Biden president of the United States
our country has demonstrated decisive
leadership
as President Biden often says
the United States will support Ukraine
for as long as it takes
we will not waver
and today at this Munich security
conference
I will then describe
what we all continue to have at stake
the moral interest
the Strategic interest
and the reason Ukraine matters
for the people of America
for the people of Europe
and for people around the world
first from the starting days of this
unprovoked war
we have witnessed
Russian forces engage in horrendous
atrocities and war crimes
their actions are an assault
on our common values
and attack
on our common Humanity
and let us be clear
Russian forces have pursued a wide
spread
and systemic attack
against a civilian population
[Music]
gruesome Acts
of murder
torture
rape and deportation
execution style killings
beatings
and electrocution
Russian authorities have forcibly
deported hundreds of thousands of people
from Ukraine to Russia
including children
they have cruelly separated children
from their families
and we've all seen the images
of the theater in maripole
were hundreds of people were killed
think of the image
of the pregnant mother
who was killed following a strike at a
maternity hospital
Where She Was preparing to give birth
think of the images of busha
civilians shot in Cold Blood
their bodies left in the street
a jarring photograph of the man who was
riding his bike
think of the four-year-old girl
who the United Nations recently reported
was sexually assaulted by a Russian
soldier
a four-year-old child
barbaric
and inhumane
long before I was vice president of the
United States
I spent the majority of my career as a
prosecutor
beginning as a young lawyer in the
courtroom
and later running the California
Department of Justice
I know firsthand
the importance of gathering facts
and holding them up against the law
in the case of Russia's actions in
Ukraine
we have examined the evidence
we know the legal standards
and there is no doubt
these are crimes against humanity
foreign
[Applause]
States has formally determined
that Russia has committed
crimes against humanity
and I say
to all those who have perpetrated these
crimes
and to their superiors
who are complicit in these crimes
you will be held
to account
in the face of these
indisputable facts
to all of us
here in Munich
let us renew
our commitment
to accountability
let us
renew
our commitment
to the rule of law
as for the United States we will
continue to support
the judicial process in Ukraine
and international investigations
because Justice must be served
let us all agree
on behalf of all the victims
both known and unknown
Justice must be served
such
is our moral interest
we also have a significant strategic
interest
the fight in Ukraine
has far-reaching Global ramifications
no nation is safe in a world where one
country can violate the sovereignty and
territorial Integrity of another
foreign
[Applause]
s Against Humanity are committed with
impunity
where a country with imperialist
ambitions
can go unchecked
our response to the Russian invasion is
a demonstration of our Collective
commitment to uphold International rules
and norms
rules and Norms which since the end of
World War II
have provided unprecedented security and
prosperity
not only for the American people
not only
for the people of Europe
but people around the world
principles that state that Sovereign
Nations have a right to peacefully exist
that borders must not be changed by
force
that there are inalienable human rights
which governments must respect
and that the rule of law must be
preserved
indeed this moment
has tested
our willingness
to defend and uphold these rules and
norms
and we have remained strong
and we must stay strong
because if Putin were to succeed with
his attack
on these fundamental principles
other nations
could feel emboldened
to follow his violent example
other authoritarian powers
could seek to bend the world to their
will
through coercion
disinformation
and even Brute Force
the international order upon which we
all rely
could be at risk
so in the interest of Global Security
and prosperity
one of our defining missions
is to uphold
International
rules-based order and Nations around the
world agree
consider more than 140 countries voted
at the United Nations to condemn
Russia's aggression
and to support Ukraine's sovereignty and
territorial integrity
in defense of the core principles of the
U.N Charter
of course
we have also seen Nations like North
Korea and Iran
send weapons and support of Russia's
brutal War
we are also troubled that Beijing
has deepened its relationship with
Moscow since the War Began
looking ahead
any steps by China
to provide lethal support to Russia
would only reward aggression
continue The Killing
and further undermine a rules-based
order
again the United States will continue to
strongly support Ukraine
and we will do so for as long as it
takes
the American people you see
are in awe
of the resolve of the people of Ukraine
in awe of their resilience and
righteousness
their willingness
to fight
for freedom and liberty
and the extraordinary tenacity and
Leadership of president zielinski
in fact joining me in Munich are
distinguished members
of the United States Congress
Republicans and Democrats
members of the House of Representatives
and the United States Senate
and they are here together
because they understand the stakes
the leadership of these members has been
vital
to America's support of Ukraine
and President Biden and I know that
their support for Ukraine will continue
we also know
Ukraine will continue to be supported by
a United
transatlantic community
[Applause]
so Putin thought he could divide NATO
remember where we were a year ago
in this he has failed
the NATO alliance is stronger now than
ever before
and the United States commitment to Nato
and to its Article 5 is Ironclad
just look at our track record over the
past year
just look at our multilateral
cooperation
together we have provided historic
assistance to Ukraine
Together We have dealt Russia a
strategic failure
together we have imposed unprecedented
costs on Russia
and together we have pursued energy
security and reinvested in our
Collective defense
and we have come together
to stand for our common values and our
common interests
and our common Humanity
I have no doubt that this Unity will
endure
I also have no Illusions about the path
forward
there will be more dark days in Ukraine
the daily Agony of War will persist
the global Ripple effects will continue
to be felt by countries near and far
from Africa
to Southeast Asia to the Caribbean
but if Putin thinks he can wait us out
he is badly mistaken
time is not on his side
to be sure
ukrainians will continue
to be tried and tested
just as they have been over this past
year
transatlantic Unity
will continue to be tried and tested
and I am certain that Ukraine will rise
to the task
that the United States and Europe will
rise to the task
so my last point
America will continue our leadership
in defense
of human dignity
in defense of rules and norms
and in defense
of freedom and liberty
there is too much at stake
to do anything less
Americans know well
the meaning of Independence
we believe in the fundamental importance
of sovereignty and rule of law
and we will always stand on the side of
Justice
colleagues
I do believe we all know
When Future Generations look back at
this moment
they will see
that we understood the task before us
and Rose
to this occasion
and so to you I say
the United States of America is proud
to be your partner in this Noble Pursuit
thank you
[Applause]
Madam vice president thank you for this
very very strong speech this commitment
to transatlantic Unity this commitment
to the support of of Ukraine and we have
many many representatives from Ukraine
here in the room and they certainly were
reassured by what you have said
let me ask you um
you confirmed this U.S support but we
all know
um next year the United States will
enter into an election campaign
we are in a democracy
we know which side of the aisle the
result will be how
sure are you that how certain are you
that what you have said that Putin who
wants to wait us out that in the end he
will not succeed
thank you Kristoff uh
as I said
I believe and I believe the American
people
understand the stakes
and the stakes being
our moral interest and our strategic
interest
I will tell you I travel around the
United States
and I have seen
the Ukrainian flag fly in places most of
you have probably never heard of in the
United States
and storefronts
in front of homes
people proudly wearing Americans proudly
wearing the colors of Ukraine
the American people
are aware of the images of busha
the American people take great pride
in a fight for independence
that being part of the foundation of our
nation
and and our principles and values
I think about where the United States is
going on this issue based on the track
record of where we've been
you only have to look at where we were a
year ago and where we are today in terms
of the contributions and resources that
America has put into everything from
ammunition to artillery to air defense
from Stingers to to Abram tanks High
Mars
Jaclyn's
I look at it in the context of the
United States Congress which is here in
force I'm told it is the largest
delegation bipartisan and bicameral of
the United States Congress to this
meeting to this Munich security
conference
and how forward the United States
Congress in a bipartisan way
has been in terms of the track record of
our support just over the last year not
to mention in a it's a technical term
called an Omnibus in our budgetary
processes but at the end of last year
dedicating another 45 billion dollars
for this upcoming year
to support Ukraine
our priority is to ensure
Ukraine's strength on the battlefield
and that is our commitment and it is a
commitment not only to the people of
Ukraine but it is a commitment to our
values
and the principles we hold dear as a
nation
and I cannot be here without also
mentioning the importance of the
alliance Europe and what it has done our
host Germany I was with Chancellor
Schultz yesterday
what we collectively have done we are
not only joined I think by our values
and our understanding of the stakes and
what is at stake in terms of a moral and
a strategic interest we have been great
colleagues in terms of pooling our
resources
coordinating our resources in a way that
I believe will give Ukraine the best
support they need to fight this fight
thank you thank you very much for this
and for The Outsiders it is indeed the
impression that this relationship this
transatlantic relationship the
relationship also producing European the
German government and the US
Administration is as strong as ever and
thank you very much for for this
um if I may nevertheless there is
something called Ira yes the inflation
reduction act
and it has raised a lot of concern on
this side of the Atlantic but we have
been reminded also by members of
Congress about c-ben on our side
um how do we prevent transatlantic Rifts
on very important question business
trade issues are very important how
confident are you that these difference
can be overcome and don't disturb this
wonderful but absolutely necessary close
transatlantic relationship
I'm very happy that you chose to raise
this topic so let me start with uh
the spirit and the intent behind the
inflation reduction act
one very important area of focus for us
has been
to address and take our responsibility
for what we must do in terms of the
climate crisis which of course is global
in nature
and so and in fact our friends in Europe
have been asking for years that we would
actually step up and do more
so under President Biden's leadership
we are proud that that that the United
States has invested an historic amount
in what we must do to take on our role
of responsibility and the climate crisis
and by that I mean we have with the
support of Congress dedicated 370
billion dollars to this effort
when I think of the impact on our
friends and the interconnection and
interdependence if you will between
whatever we do in each of or any of our
Nations and the effect on the others we
think of this investment as having a
global impact in predominantly two ways
one
the United States
I'd say this sadly is one of the biggest
emitters in the world
and we need to reduce our emissions
not only for the sake of the health and
well-being of the people of our own
country but as we know the people of the
world are impacted
so this is an an historic and and very
significant investment to actually turn
the tide on that and as you know as as
many of our European friends and and
others around the globe have done we
have set strict standards for ourselves
based on timelines so there is that
which is the goal of reducing emissions
the other piece of it is we are very
excited about thinking about the
investment that we are making to Spur
innovation
we are entering a moment where we are
creating a new economy a clean energy
economy
and
do you think of us as being an investor
if you will in creating incentives for
the private sector for for scientists
and academics to research develop and
innovate around a clean energy economy
this investment that we are making will
do that and have Global impact
so that is how we think of it but to
your point there are also issues that we
need to address and do that in close
consultation with our friends around the
world we have created a task force the
United States EU task force closely
coordinating and in consultation around
working out some of the specific
concerns and those conversations are
continuing I met with President macron
yesterday and Chancellor Schultz and I
think we are seeing some progress there
and the work will continue
no thank you for this reaffirmation
because we don't need this quarrels and
at that time if time allows
um one last question if I may this
Munich security conference
um is of course dedicated to Ukraine to
the support of Ukraine to confirm the
transatlantic Alliance but we have
widened the participation this year we
have invited a record number of
representatives from the so-called
Global South because while we have this
Unity between us when you talk to
representatives of the global South and
we had them on the podium this morning
you see that many countries sit on the
fence they they see this as kind of a
continuation of the conflict between us
and Russia or NATO and EU and European
countries and and Russia and they feel
the consequences and they want to get it
over over with they have an equidistant
position there and while we had and you
pointed to the 141 votes but when you
talk to important Partners in the global
South said they they are they abstain
they um you know say get it over with we
don't want to take
take one side and the point we're making
of course is this is not East West this
is
about the rule space internal the rule
of law that you mentioned but
we have to do some convincing because
our track record is also not the best so
what can we do also together
to win over those countries that
continue to sit on the fence
well we have to treat them as partners
and you and I talked about this briefly
as we were walking in and I thank you
and I will thank you in front of the
friends for for bringing this issue to
the stage and making it a part of the
agenda for this conference
I agreed as an important subject
and I have met with many African leaders
leaders in the Caribbean
CARICOM in Southeast Asia and
what
I believe is that they are right to want
to make sure their voices are heard on
every level on this topic including the
impact to their Nations
you look at for example African nations
and what the Russia's aggression in
Ukraine has meant in terms of food
insecurity
energy and security and these are
nations as we know that are great
importers of food and energy so when the
supply decreases it has a significant
impact on their Nations so I think it is
important for us to recognize the impact
that Russia's War has had on these
nations I think of it in the context of
what we must do to also on the previous
discussion consider the impact to The
Climate crisis of the climate crisis on
those Nations
we are some of the biggest emitters
and the impacts are clear I meet with
CARICOM Nations so island nations in the
Caribbean
and they tell me about how they're
seeing land erosion
how they are seeing through uh through
the extreme climate
occurrences reduction in tourism and
what that means in terms of a depletion
of their GDP
and so these are issues that we must
keep in mind when we uh when we have
this discussion with them as partners
around what the solutions look like
including standing
in a unified way on these principles of
sovereignty and territorial integrity
my friend the president of Ghana I
believe spoke yesterday and I think he
captured it well when
I'm going to paraphrase but my
understanding is he said that we need to
dispense with this Paradigm that is
about us versus them
and think differently
about the relationship that we have
and for all of those reasons I thank you
for raising this and I think it is
worthy of the type of elevation and the
discussion that you are giving it
thank you thank you very much for this
and this will remain a theme here we'll
discuss this also next year and maybe
um Madam vice president can we already
book a hotel room so you come back next
year thank you for being here please
hand off
[Applause]